c'est ici à Guille en cours sur ces 22
hectares en friche de l'ancien site
Talès que doit voir le jour le nouveau
quartier d'habitation proche de la
future station de métro de la ligne 18
problème un désaccord entre le maire de
la ville et la communauté
d'agglomération concernant son
aménagement finalement on se demande qui
préside vraiment la communauté
d'agglomération je prenais l'image d'un
d'un avion sans pilote moi je préfère
presque celle d'un avion qui dans la
cabine verrait plusieurs pilotes se
disputer le manche ce qui est dangereux
quand on veut définir une direction tant
que la communauté d'agglomération de C
an en Yveline connaîtra de véritables
anomalies euh dans son fonctionnement
mais aussi dans sa gouvernance mais
encore dans ses relations avec les
communes il n'est pas envisageable de
confier des projets d'aménagement par
exemple à guillencour dans ce contexte
François de Ligier refuse de confier ce
projet à Saint-Quentin en Yveline mais
aussi tous les autres projets
d'aménagement à venir sur sa commune il
s'agit encore d'une posture du maire de
guireocour le terrainalais depuis le
début on fonctionne ensemble et aucune
décision n'a été prise s'il y avait pas
de concordance dans notre vision des
choses je vous rappelle que à
l'unanimité là aussi nous avons voté que
ce terrain soit racheté euh par
l'établissement pfoncier des ilides pour
le compte de l'agglomération de 50bl
concernant l'aménagement du site un
comité de pilotage s'est réuni ce mardi
après-midi selon le maire en cours le
préfet aurait décidé à brève échéance
d'organiser une consultation d'urbanisme
et de confier la maîtrise d'ouvrage à le
PAA de Paris saclé